You are listening to radio lab radio from W N Y.
S e n n.
P. R. Everybody level check.
We're going to start the show with this fellow. His name's Ben Zimmer.
He's the on language columnist for the New York Times magazine because we
figured since we wanted to do a show called at right,
we thought we should call Ben.
And so we came into the studio and he brought with him a bunch of his favorite.
Oops. As an example. I just wanted to give one of my favorite examples of a,
the first one that he hit us with, uh, began its life. Was it in an AP,
a news article?
Mm. Well, it was an AP story,
but the AP story was fine when the AP story appeared on a news site from the
American family association, which by the way is a conservative Christian group.
Um, the headline, first of all,
said homosexual eases into 100 final at Olympic trials
and then kissing guys or something that could be good at, well, if you read on,
if you're confused by that headline, very, here's how it starts.
Tyson homosexual easily won his semi-final for the a hundred meters at the u s
Olympic track and field trials. And it goes on to say, you know,
throughout the entire article, you know, on Saturday,
homosexual misjudge the finish in his opening heat,
the entire article had the word homosexual in place of gay.
The sprinters name is Tyson [inaudible].
Yes. According to Ben, this is a classic,
classic example of a search and replace, oops.
This group apparently did not like the word gay because gay makes homosexuality
sound very nice and they're gay, gay, gay.
So what they did was they ran a search and replace every instance of the word
gay with the word homosexual,
but then you get Tyson gay becoming Tyson homosexual.
This was just a one that they were a little careless with.
Just to be fair, here's a contrasting example. In 1990,
the FRIZZ Newbie ran martyr.
What about the, uh,
Massachusetts budget crisis and it made reference to new taxes that will help
put Massachusetts quote back into the African American. Um,
and they had to issue a correction saying it should have said back in the day,
Black, oh no, this one might've been a newsroom prank. We're not sure,
but it didn't get into paper just for the hell of it. Here's one last one.
This one happened after the famous broadcast, or Walter Cronkite died
when the Chicago Tribune did their online obituary for Cronkite.
What happened was every instance of Cronkite got replaced by Mr Cronkite.
You can understand the thinking behind that. They deciding, okay,
for deceased males, they should be referred to with the title Mister.
But then what this turns into is a,
an obituary where it says he was born Walter Leland, Mr Cronkite,
and he refers to his radio show, Walter, Mr [inaudible], the 20th century.
It's got things about his family has his son, Walter, Mr Cronkite, the third,
his daughter, his daughter Kathy, Mr Cranky,
my heart went, Ooh, Jed. The moment that my heart went, Ooh,
and I'm Robert, I never will forget to this episode of Radio Lab.
The moment that I'm mad for
oopses starting with a tree, oops. Then we've got a goose
and an entire town that, oops. And a Harvard professor
that really it. Yeah. No, we should just say before we start, oops. Oops.
Is oops, can be a misleading term.
Really what we're talking about here is something Greek. Well,
you try hard to prevent one thing and then you get exactly what you didn't want
to get back at you. Right. And our first story falls into that category.
Back a few seasons ago,
we were doing a show on deception and we ended up talking with a professor. Yes.
Named Ruben Gore. Hello. Hi. Is this professor Gar? Yes. Speaking.
He's a psychiatrist. Works at the University of Pennsylvania.
And I'd called them to talk about his research on self deception,
self deception. It's fascinating stuff.
And I'm not going to go into it now because somewhere along the way,
the conversation took a really weird turn. No. Oh yeah.
Get it out. Yeah. Yeah.
And it happened when he began to tell me about some studies,
range off studies done by a, uh, what was the guy's name?
His name is hanging on it.
Okay.
I don't remember. Second.
MMM. MMM Marie.
What's his name? Henry Murray.
And the reason we want to hear about Henry Murray is what? I built it up.
Don't you want to know more than this yet? No. You gotta tell me why. Okay.
I'm going to let it unfold because we were so interested in what rubigard told
us that we found a guy. Oh, hi. How's it going?
Who knows a whole lot about professor. Mary's name is Austin Chase.
Very windy day today, isn't it?
And he lives in a remote cabin in Mon Danna.
Got another one in the woods in the foothills.
Professor Murray was a very prestigious scholar.
He had been a professor of psychology at Harvard before the Second World War.
During the war. He, uh,
went to work for the [inaudible] office of strategic services,
which was the forerunner of the CIA in a couple of years into his government
service, says Austin. Something happened.
It really spooked him and spooked the country during the Korean War.
Uh, there were some Gis, he said he'd been captured in Korea and afterwards,
after the Korean War, they refused to come home. They appeared to have,
I betrayed their country.
We know their own country and disappeared behind Red China.
Benton boob. Correct. Anybody wants to go home.
Gia and their military establishment was very much concerned that the communists
had found techniques for brainwashing.
And so Marie and other psychiatrists in the government were charged with
preparing XO soldiers to resist that kind of brainwashing.
And Marie himself developed a style of interrogation.
Stressful interrogation was the term used at the army could use on its pilots.
Yeah.
He developed this method of kidnapping them before they were sent them to
mission. Yeah.
And then says Ruben Gore, he'd run them through a battery of tests.
Let's just see if they break and if they didn't break, they were fine to fly.
This kind of psychological training was most kind of a new front in the Cold War
and in the 1950s Marie's back at Harvard and he's thinking of ways to fine tune
his techniques and this is where things get interesting.
He took a clash of Harvard undergraduates, 20 some odd sophomores,
mostly students were told to write an autobiographical essay, like a diary.
And he told them, you know what, make it very personal, right, your deep,
his thoughts in their harsh aspirations and hopes while you're at it,
right about your sexual fantasies.
Go ahead or class and after the students were done he said to them,
now I'm going to pair you up into groups of two to debate or discuss what they'd
written. Students were like, okay, we'll share.
No big deal, but they were duped.
They were walked into this very brightly lit bro.
We just turned out to be an interrogation room with a one way mirror,
put in a chair strapped
electro to attach to their arms, chest,
their heart to measure stress basically,
and they were also filming through the mirror and then instead of a classmate in
walks, a total stranger, older man, this guy was holding their essay,
they didn't know it,
but Marie had trained to do everything he could to anger and humiliate the
undergraduate and he just tore them apart piece by piece using the essay,
the mock shooting aspirations and thoughts.
Then after this was done,
the students have to come back week after week to view themselves on film being
humiliated. That to me seems like the worst part. After they'd been humiliated,
they had to watch themselves being humiliated over and over.
People became tearful and miserable and he was proud how he destroyed people.
What, what
kind of person is this? Like why did he do it? Yeah, why Bari did it.
There were any one of a number of explanations and they all could be true.
One is it was a grant grabbing. He was getting money to do these things.
I'll say, you know, this was the Cold War.
He was fighting communism may have thought it was justified. Yeah, but, but he,
but he just said he was proud of this. Well,
it also happens to be the case that he was having an affair for about 30 years
with a woman, not his wife,
and they had a sexual relationship that bordered on the shadow mash.
In fact, wash sadomasochistic another words,
Moorish interest in these was intentionally personal,
whatever the case in those Harvard experiments,
there was one student who is just not prepared for any of it.
His code name was lawful, lawful.
They gave each of these students our code name because he was considered so
conventional. He was really still just a boy.
Graduated High School at 16 I was living a thousand miles from home,
two shirts and two trousers to his name and lawful.
Apparently within especially lonely kid notes,
I found Marie did refer specifically to lawful chache,
which she shies highly a eight and eight so when lawful walked into that room,
sat across from that stranger.
The guy really did a job on him. He was young,
so he was barely growing a beard. So the first thing that guy tells him is,
what is this on your chin? Something trying to look like a beard.
Then the guy opens up lawfully essay and lets him have it. Meanwhile,
like all the students, lawful had been hooked up to all these stress monitor.
I analyzed his data,
compare it to all the other participants he had firing await strongest response.
Physiologically, you mean like his heartbeat, the fastest beat everything.
Amazingly,
this experiment went on for three years and decades later a lot of the subjects
were still upset and considered it one of the most traumatic experiences they'd
had in their 20s lawful never forgot it. That's right.
It was resentful at the way he was treated at Harvard.
He had nightmares about Professor Murray after he left Harvard.
So what happened to this guy? Oh,
well he finished up his four years at Harvard,
got his degree and got a phd in math.
Then he began to teach math and then he became a household name.
What do you mean? Well, I mean this,
yes,
Bi raid began just afternoon in a remote mountainous area called Stemple pass
about five miles outside the town of Lincoln, Montana.
Turns out that lawfully real name your door [inaudible]? No.
Oh yeah. [inaudible] was, no. Yeah.
P I dubbed him the Unabomber in nearly 18 years.
He found targets all over the country.
He is meticulously made bombs or killed three people and injured another 23.
Blew my arm off to the side like this. And, uh,
the first thing I thought was why did they do that? Do you think that this study
he had anything to do with, uh,
Ted Cruz in skis subsequent very infamous acts?
Well, I think he probably would have, if it hadn't been for that experiment,
he still,
it probably would've been maybe reclusive living somewhere in a cabin in one
time, regardless.
But I think the evil twist was what was done there.
Years later, while he was researching a book, Austin corresponded
with Kozinski
and one of his letters,
he mentioned that he participated in some psychological experiments conducted by
profession. Marie, of course,
I was very curious and I wrote it back to tell me a little bit more about it.
And he shed while you really don't,
I don't know if you want to go into that can of worms.
[inaudible]
Rubin Gore is a professor of psychiatry at University of Pennsylvania and Austin
Chase is the author of the book Harvard and the making of the Unabomber.
Hello?
[inaudible].
Oops. Oops. Oops.
Here's one more
from Ben Zimmer. What is the Cupertino effect?
The Cupertino affects is the name given to the phenomenon of when you rely on a
spellchecker too much,
it will give you a suggestion and very often it's a suggestion that you really
shouldn't take. Why is it called the Cupertino effect? Well,
in early spell checkers, if you wrote cooperation,
the word cooperation, c, O, O, p, e r, a, T, I, o. N,
it perfectly typical spelling of the word cooperation in early spellcheckers.
Um, that word was not there because it expected you to spell it c o Hyphen.
And so what it would do is it would give you a suggestion and the suggestion was
Cupertino in another town in California.
So if you look at documents that are still online from the UN,
from the EU, from NATO,
you'll find dozens and dozens of Cupertino's that have found their way in there.
For instance, a here's a German NATO officer was quoted as saying,
the Cupertino with our Italian comrade proved to be very fruitful.
And then there was a proposal from the EU scientific and technical research
committee. They proposed quote, stimulating cross-border Cupertino.
Oops. Number two, you go the the next,
this is the next one is just a different flavor entirely.
We're going to meet someone. I don't know.
I can't really say they did anything wrong. It's just,
I mean this one is more like, like what'd you say? Luck mixed.
Supposed you just picked up a toothbrush and it was connected to a snake that
was connected to a monster that was connected to the devil himself.
Now you wouldn't know. You're just picking up a tooth.
So this is a case where we really bad things happen. The story comes from our,
our own reporter. Pat Walter's. Yeah, it concerns. Why don't you go ahead and,
okay, so just to start, I want you to imagine you're on a mountain top.
Okay. This mountain is in western Nevada.
The second highest peak in the state of Nevada got a name,
it's called wheeler peak and it was this, this is Michael Cohen.
I go by Michael Pico and he's a nature writer and he tells me that up on top of
this mountain there is a grove of old trees.
You can see the trees from a distance and Eric Wood is so bright that it
actually glistens in the sun. What do they call it? Oh,
bristle cone pines. Yes. Can you describe what they look like? Sure.
They tend to be shorter, broad at the base. They get very,
very old and as they get old they become towards your door.
[inaudible] they sort of twist up towards the sky.
The overall effect is sort of electrical.
They look kind of like what you'd seen a Tim Burton movie.
So you have that picture? Yeah, I combined. Yup. Okay,
so the story is about the scientist named Don Curry.
I'm going to take a drink of water. Wait, I'm going to take a drink of water.
Okay.
Story starts in 1964 don curry was a graduate student from North Carolina and he
was young. Do we know how old he was?
He was 30 years old and he'd just gotten a big grant from the national science
foundation to do some climate change research.
Not like climate change now though climate change thousands of years ago because
he learned that you could actually sort of travel back in time,
go back into the past using this spacing between tree rings,
the annual rings. This is Ron Lanner,
he's a retired forest service scientist and he says you can use the width of the
tree rings to determine whether it was colder at one time or Rainier at one
period in the tree's life or whatever.
So curry is up on top of this mountain up amongst these trees and he needs to
find one that he can look inside and kind of see what the weather was like.
Way Back in the,
the past five minutes of looking is all it was involved.
This is from a Nova documentary.
Carrie died a few years ago and this is actually the only time that he ever
talked about this story on tape. Literally, he found a tree there,
first old tree that we find too, that uh,
he had described as looking super, super old.
So curry takes out this special drill,
which scientists used to take like a core sample to look at the rings. Yeah,
I'll press it up against the tree,
give it a good push to get it through the bar.
And he starts twisting it in clockwise into the tree.
But he wasn't having much luck.
The normal approach to coring the tree wasn't working.
It becomes harder and harder for him to turn this thing into the tree.
And eventually
the bit of his drill broke off in the tree. Oh,
this isn't just any drill.
He ordered it from Sweden and the whole time he's thinking,
if I can't get this thing out of the tree,
that would mean the research project would be lost for the year.
So at this point,
he kind of lumbers back the mountain and a dejected.
He managed to find the, uh,
district ranger and told him the problem guys might drill.
It got stuck in the tree, what should I do? And they tell him,
don't worry about it. Then we'll just cut the tree down. This is one tree.
There are dozens of these trees all around,
so they start slicing into the tree.
It takes awhile to cut it down cause it's really dense or not.
Some are old and eventually the tree
falls over.
Then they cut some slabs out of the lower part of the tree.
Curry gets one of these slabs back to his lab, throws it on a big desk,
find a magnifying glass because the rings are really small and he starts
counting one, two, three and as he counts,
he's making little pin holes or pencil marks every 50 year, a hundred years,
three 17 by the end of the first day nine he gets back to a thousand years like
the dark ages where in Europe eating raw pasta.
Day Two,
2006 by the middle of the day he gets back to like Jesus,
Roman Empire, gladiators and Centurion.
But even at that point he was only like halfway finished. He kept counting.
We can begin to see that we were getting over 4,000 years.
Over 4,500 over 4,600 and we ended up around 4,900 years.
4,844 annual rings in it.
And at that point,
the oldest tree that anyone had ever found was 4,600 years old.
In other words, he had himself the oldest tree ever,
but he had killed it. And you've got to think,
I've got to have done something wrong. I better recount. I better recount again.
But no matter how many times he counted the rings, the number never went down.
[inaudible]
the world's oldest tree was dead.
It was. It was truly, it was horrifying. It was a,
it was a like a family tragedy.
Uh,
people had given these trees names.
There was Buddha and Socrates and Methuselah.
They called Curry's tree, the prometheus's tree.
And the guy who named that particular tree was so angry that he wrote a magazine
article where he called Don Curry, a murderer all across the country.
There is a tremendous uproar. Same thing.
What about killing the world's oldest living organism?
What I thought we would just say he was, I think was the oldest living tree.
It's, it's both.
It's the oldest tree and it's the oldest organism. It wait, wait, wait.
You mean that the oldest continuously living
okay.
And [inaudible] shrub mushroom, eh. Oh,
you making you sure about this? [inaudible] get his head with,
this is the oldest living continuous individual alive on the planet.
I know what I said. This true was older than any other tree on the planet.
Older than the oldest sponge,
which is like 1500 years old and older than the oldest animal.
Just some sort of oyster, which is 405 years old.
Older than any other living thing on the entire planet.
Oh God.
Where do we go? Here we go from there. So where does that leave? Mr. Curry. Oh,
so what happened to him? Well, right after this happened,
curry pretty much stopped doing research on trees.
He basically studied salt flats for the rest of his career.
[inaudible]
big treeless salt flats.
And aside from that little Nova clip that we played before,
he hasn't really ever gone on record talking about this.
It's hard for us to say like how we really felt about it.
There was this one moment he was being interviewed by a TV reporter,
like about his salt flats research,
and this would have been in the 19 probably the late eighties early nineties
years and years after the whole tree incident.
All of a sudden they out of a clear blue sky
[inaudible]
the television reporter asked him, oh,
aren't you the curry who killed the world's oldest tree?
[inaudible] he was completely
[inaudible].
Curry just turned his back and ran away.
[inaudible]
who is it? That's a stage. Just pick for forever. We're off somebody.
Look on your, the need.
He did have the incredible Mr switching to kill the oldest living organism on
our planet. Yeah,
but this is 25 years later and he's still getting hassled about this tree.
We're talking about one tree here. Well, no, we're talking about the tree here,
right,
but thing about a tree that lasts for four almost 4,000 more than that.
5,000 almost five years. Sure. Is that the, it is a repository.
It is a talisman for 5,000 years of earth history. But I mean, would it be,
would it be any less bad if the tree were three and a half thousand years old?
This is just one more old thing. No, it is.
It's the oldest of all taking like the Guinness Book of World Records. Oh,
you keep making me into like a Ripley's believe it or not guy. But no,
that's exactly what you were being. No, no, no. There's a,
when you've been around longer than everybody else,
there's a certain number of her experience. Yeah. Well,
I'm older than you. I,
I walk in here and I look at you and I feel pity for other things.
You don't know your shit or what tree must have
fell in. Right.
But it must've been around Jack that was your boy and Pat Walters.
But a mother use the route and we're happy to say that since our original
broadcast, that the story, a new oldest living tree has been found,
it's also a bristle cone pine also in the white mountains, and it's current age.
According to Dr. Peter Brown of the Rocky Mountain Tree Ring Research Group is
just about 5,060 years old,
which makes it actually older than don Curry's tree when it was cut down.
So Don Curry, if you're out there listening from the afterlife,
you can now rest in peace. We'll continue in a moment.